SECOND THOUGHTS?
KIND OF?
ABOUT CONGRESSIONAL SPENDING?
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
ALL RIGHT.
LAST NIGHT WE TOLD YOU ABOUT THE
$1.3 TRILLION OMNIBUS SPENDING
BILL UNDER CONSIDERATION BY
CONGRESS.
THIS IS IT.
LOOK AT THIS.
LOOK AT THIS THING.
THIS IS A TENTH OF IT RIGHT
HERE.
WE DON'T WANT TO KILL ALL THE
TREES, SO WE ONLY PRINTED OUT A
TENTH OF IT.
BUT WE DID THE MATH, AND THIS IS
HOW BIG IT IS.
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE READING THIS
BILL?
NO ONE'S READING THE BILL.
THIS IS WHAT IT IS.
OKAY?
THIS IS THE REPUBLICAN CONGRESS.
IT'S A BUSINESS AS USUAL
SPEND-ORAMA WHERE THE VOTERS
EXPECTED THE OPPOSITE.
WELL, IS THE SEQUESTER CAP GONE?
WHAT ARE THE REPUBLICANS DOING?
THEY'RE LINKING ARMS WITH
DEMOCRATS.
YES, THEY'RE SPENDING MORE ON
THINGS WE SHOULD NOT BE FUNDING
AT ALL.
AND THINGS THE PRESIDENT VOWED
TO DEFUND.
SO HOW ON EARTH DO REPUBLICANS
EXPECT THE VOTERS TO TURN OUT IN
NOVEMBER FOR THEM IF THEY CAN'T
LIVE UP TO THE BASIC PRECEPTS OF
WHAT THEY CAMPAIGNED ON?
THIS RIDICULOUS OMNIBUS, LET'S
KEEP MOVING THE CAMERA ANGLES
HERE, BUT PEOPLE HAVE TO SEE
WHAT THIS IS, BECAUSE YOU DON'T
REALLY GET IT IF YOU DON'T SEE
IT.
LOOK AT THIS THING.
AGAIN, I WANT YOU TO SEE THIS.
THIS IS YOUR TAX DOLLARS AT
WORK.
THIS IS IT.
$1.6 BILLION IN THIS DISASTER IS
DEVOTED TO BORDER SECURITY.
THAT'S IT.
A PALTRY $641 MILLION TO THE
WALL THE PRESIDENT CAMPAIGNED
ON.
AND NOT EVEN CLOSE TO WHAT THE
PRESIDENT REQUESTED TO ENSURE
THE WALL ACTUALLY GOT BUILT.
I RAISED THIS CONCERN AND OTHERS
TO MAJORITY WHIT STEVE SCALISE.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY,
CONGRESSMAN, TO DEFUND SANCTUARY
CITIES AND TO GET THE REAL MONEY
FOR THE WALL THAT THE PRESIDENT
CAMPAIGNED ON, AND HE WON THE
ELECTION ON THAT WALL.
DEFUND PLANNED PARENTHOOD, HALF
A BILLION DOLLARS.
I KNOW YOU AGREE WITH ME ON
THIS.
THE REPUBLICANS ARE IN CHARGE
AND THEY PUNTED.
THAT IS MIND BOG WILL
THAT IS MIND BOG WIL
THAT IS MIND-BOG WIL
THAT IS MIND-BOGGLIL
THAT IS MIND-BOGGLIN
THAT IS MIND-BOGGLING
THAT IS MIND-BOGGLING T
THAT IS MIND-BOGGLING TO
THAT IS MIND-BOGGLING TO ME
THAT IS MIND-BOGGLING TO ME.
HE SAID, HE AGREES WITH US.
PERHAPS THE PRESIDENT WAS
ACTUALLY WATCHING THE ANGLE, I
HOPE SO.
EARLIER TODAY, HE RECONSIDERED
HIS SUPPORT OF THE OMNIBUS BILL
AND CALLED RYAN AND McKONLD TO
THE WHITE HOUSE FOR A MEETING.
IN A STATEMENT, WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY SARAH SANDERS
ANNOUNCED THE PRESIDENT AND THE
LEADERS DISCUSSED THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL, WHICH INCLUDES
MORE FUNDS TO REBUILD THE
MILITARY, SUCH AS THE LARGEST
PAY RAISE FOR OUR TROOPS IN A
DECADE, MORE THAN 100 MILES OF
NEW CONSTRUCTION FOR THE BORDER
WALL, AND OTHER KEY DOMESTIC
PRIORITIES, LIKE COMBATING THE
OPIOID CRISIS AND REBUILDING OUR
NATION'S INFRASTRUCTURE.
HMM.
NOW, THIS IS CURIOUS.
RYAN AND McCONNELL OBVIOUSLY
PUSHED THE PRESIDENT TO SUPPORT
THE BILL -- THERE ARE SOME GOOD
THINGS IN THE BILL -- BUT THE
BIG PUSH WAS MR. PRESIDENT, YOU
CANNOT ARD
CANNOT AR
CANNOT AFF
CANNOT AFFOR
CANNOT AFFORD
CANNOT AFFORD A
CANNOT AFFORD A G
CANNOT AFFORD A GOV
CANNOT AFFORD A GOVER
CANNOT AFFORD A GOVERNM
CANNOT AFFORD A GOVERNMEN
CANNOT AFFORD A GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN ON FRIDAY.
THAT'S HOW THEY DO IT, THEY MAKE
YOU AGREE TO BLOW YOUR PROMISES
AND PRINCIPLES TO PUT A GUN TO
YOUR HEAD.
THIS WILL BE TERRIBLE, SHUT THE
GOVERNMENT DOWN.
IT PAINS ME TO SAY THIS, BUT THE
PRESIDENT IS BUYING A PIG IN A
POKE HERE.
HE WON ON CALLING OUT THE
ESTABLISHMENT, ON NAMING NAMES,
YES, EVEN WHEN IT MADE THINGS
UNCOMFORTABLE.
SO I HAVE A QUESTION.
WHERE DID THAT DONALD TRUMP GO?
AND WHERE DOES ALL OUR MONEY GO
IN THIS BILL THAT'S EVEN TOO BIG
FOR US TO SHOW ON CAMERA
REGULARLY?
IT'S MONEY WE DON'T HAVE THAT WE
WILL HAVE TO BORROW FROM JAPAN,
GERMANY.
THE PENTAGON BUDGET BALLOONS TO
AN OBSCENE $700 BILLION.
THAT'S MORE THAN $80 BILLION
OVER CURRENT LIMITS.
YES, I SAID $80 BILLION.
SANCTUARY CITIES?
FULLY FUNDED.
JERRY BROWN'S HAPPY.
PLANNED PARENTHOOD?
A HALF A BILLION DOLLARS.
AND SOMETHING CALLED, GET THIS,
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT BLOCK
GRANTS TO CITIES.
THAT'S, BY THE WAY, WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WANTED STRIPPED
FROM THIS BUDGET, NEARLY DOUBLED
TO $5.2 BILLION.
AND THEN THERE'S THE OBAMA ERA
TRANSPORTATION GRANT PROGRAM
KNOWN AS TIGER.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS.
I LOVE TIGERS, BUT I CAN'T LOVE
THIS.
THIS WOULD HAVE ITS BUDGET
TRIPLED TO $1.5 BILLION.
I COULD GO ON AND ON AND ON.
WE'VE ONLY GOT AN HOUR TONIGHT.
IF I WERE ADVISING THE
TAKE THIS AS AN OPPORTUNITY
TONIGHT TO CHALLENGE THE GOP
LEADERSHIP.
THERE WOULD BE NO SIGNATURE ON
THE OMNIBUS BILL WITHOUT A
GUARANTEE OF FULL FUNDING FOR